[Music]
you
nah thank you for joining me thanks for
having me well why are you calling from
from Tel Aviv deep inside the quarantine
deep in said well 12,000 kilometers away
deep inside the quarantine and I'm
enjoying it because all of a sudden
everybody like you has time to talk to
me so this is great well I think that
actually people have less time now in
quarantine because you don't actually
have separation between the work day and
the night so you just work the entire
day so having things like that is just
you know a really good kind of get away
from my work and it's kind of
interesting that now especially in Dec
with people that are able to work more
you know a lot of people are either laid
off for others or you know road maps are
all of a sudden being are coming to a
stop and and you know a lot of the
deadlines or all of a sudden really up
in the air and you know and it's really
it's a really interesting time how is it
for auto now and what you guys are doing
I've surprised a little bit different we
so I'm one of the founders of auto
security we provide a remote access
solution for employees to work from home
so that's actually pretty good for us
we're not complaining about the
situation obviously we want this to end
but yeah we're it's it's not bad for
business
well actually realizing how important it
is to work to provide a secure and easy
remote access solution so for us
probably not the best startup to
represent what's going on in the
industry right now right so okay so
cyber security and and secure mode
access what does that even mean
I have no idea so well let's say that in
the old days things were much easier
people would physically go to their
place of work physically turn on the
computer and actually plug in the the
network cable to log into the network so
thanks for just you know very physical
but obviously nowadays it's not no
longer like that so companies started to
expand expand their headquarters moving
resources to different cloud providers
and just
no different data centers around the
world and also employees started working
more and more from home from different
devices so basically if in the old days
you could just you know surround your
network with virtual walls but if I want
the entrance which was kind of like a
bodyguard saying who can and who cannot
access this is no longer like that
because you can't really put walls
around the entire world
right what is what is actually what is
the solution that you guys are offering
yeah
so um let's say the standard solution
currently our VPNs
so it's essentially VPNs tend for a
virtual private network so it's
essentially creating one big network out
of your different locations around the
world obviously it's it's not secure
even even saying that I think that's
pretty obvious you just create one giant
open network where everyone can just a
login good productivity but very very
bad for security and the more you try to
fight it the more overhead it cost
causes so what we do is just connect
users to individual resources of the
company no matter where they sit so we
can connect a user to one resource from
each different data center around the
world we really don't care and it's also
commended so this user can only access
those resources and everything else is
completely blackened for him okay so I
mean the whole the whole cyber security
scene has been on it on a crazy uprising
over the past 10-15 years give me you
know your two cents and as a founder of
one of these companies what is happening
in the cyber security space and why is
it why do we see such a boom and do you
think this boom is going to continue
increasing or raises just like you know
a 21st century fad that's gonna die out
in the next few years
ya know so that's a really good question
a lot of people look at the cyber
security space as a bubble I don't think
it's true simply because as long as
they're prop there will be progress
there will be need for cyber security I
know it's really cliche but that's just
you know how things are you progressed
you let's say the cloud and then there
are new potential risks and let's say
Penny's choose to ignore it so then
there is an opportunity for an attacker
a new way of work and you a new
opportunity to whatever make money
you're just you know hurt her to some
companies and then the need kind of
feeds itself so to answer your question
yeah well again good for us and
unfortunately for the world I believe
that cybersecurity is just it's here to
stay and it will be constantly growing
alongside new technologies so now let's
go a little bit higher and you know I'm
now studying in University and it's not
very common for students to to do a deep
dive into cybersecurity in the current
system of come in the current major
that's called computer science you know
even within the major when we choose our
tracks I don't believe there is a
specific cybersecurity track in most
institutions very unlike you know what
we did in the in the Army so Israel is
very well known for training its
soldiers also in the cyber security
space do you think this is this is
something that needs to change how do
people around the world actually get
equipped what the skill sets needed for
this yeah so usually I would believe it
comes from networking and probably
curiosity so just you know truckers or
or people I'm networking with computers
so this is also how I got into cyber
security obviously like you said also
from the Israeli army but I was just
really curious about computer networking
and how this entire infrastructure is
actually actually work so I mean in my
opinion it's just it's it's crazy I mean
look take us back you know 50 years we
didn't have those things and I didn't
have an internet so just the way it is
all structured is it's really wonderful
in my in my opinion so probably you know
you start out of curiosity continue to
kind of learn and see how those things
were structured probably I believe that
if you don't have any university
education to come from from work so
usually if you work anything in
IP or networking anywhere in that that
region sure so you know just as
cybersecurity is while in Israel maybe
there may be a proliferation of
companies dealing with it around the
world it's still pretty fresh and what's
even more fresh is seeing women in
positions of leadership and tech
companies and and I'd love to get your
take on you know i-i've been I talked
quite a bit with addy suffered to any
about this to various organizations so I
she has her own opinions about it what
what do you think is happening now and
what needs to happen so that more women
getting to leadership positions like
you're in right now it's a pretty good
question I think well again not saying
anything new but obviously thinks it
starts with education so the earlier
you're exposed to tech in general the or
you'll be inclined to adopt it I think
this is something that is a very
different it's a really good question
because also I can say that in my unit I
I served in unit I 200 which is kind of
you know famous in the Israeli army and
I can say that I had a lot of female
friends over there that that worked with
with computers and networking and a very
very big part of them actually continued
to software engineering or or even cyber
security so I think it's just about the
exposure the more exposed you are the
more likely you are to like it and adopt
it right do you get I mean obviously
people are not gonna necessarily shot
but do you feel that there's some sort
of elephant in the room when it comes to
seeing a bright woman in a leadership
position for a cyber security company
today what do you mean a mountain
elephant a room if there's if there's
any sense of if there's any sense of you
know surprise because if I bet that if
you look at the at the industry now of
cyber security companies most of the
leadership positions are held by men
and all of a sudden here we have we have
a very bright woman who's the chief
product officer of one of the most of
the one of the most promising cyber
security companies in Israel is do you
get any any feedback on that or is this
just something that people are accepting
as it is so I think that and here I
should really say thank you to all the
you know amazing women that came before
me and kind of paved the road for that I
think I think we're in really good times
I think it's a good time to be to be a
woman especially in those areas yeah
yeah so a lot of the times it'll be
surprising my name is Noah so that's a
very common Israeli man for girls but us
obviously with an H at the end that's
the guys names a lot of people get
confused I don't actually feel it
they're they're surprised in the bad way
I usually feel they're surprised in the
good way no no of course I meant
obviously in the good way yeah you know
yeah I'm saying that so it's it's
actually a good time to be women I think
that also feces are much more open to
wanting to have a female member in the
founding team I think that's oh yeah so
important you know in general diversity
yeah yeah thing because I just I just
did a big venture capitalist class at
Stanford with one of the top VC's in the
valley and and and the founding member
of that VC made it very clear that she
values companies much higher when in the
founding team there's at least one or or
50% female leadership and which I mean
makes perfect sense I mean it's about
women and men it can be you know
different versity any day yes again um
this this word has became kind of you
know so common you kind of want to throw
up but at the end of the day you can
really feel it you just you know
different people think differently and
it's always good to have multiple
opinions and we can really fit it in our
company amazing so I'd love to hear
about what is it like being a chief
product officer of a company that's you
know really
growing quickly and is probably shifting
a lot throughout the way and a lot of it
is standing on your plate because you
have to make some tough decisions when
it comes to which products you're
building and how is it gonna look a year
from now as you're scaling so I'd love
to hear about some of these challenges
yeah sure so from each was actually like
a double challenge because I'm not
coming from a product management
experience before this role I served as
a frog Jam developer in Google yeah so
now it's a bit of working with like
product features but not actually
prioritizing and creating the
requirements I have to say that I love
this the the product management position
it's just it's kind of the perfect role
for me specifically from from a founders
perspective as well so I have to say
that I wasn't exactly sure about my role
in the company when we started so I have
two brilliant talented co-founders one
in the CEO position than the other in
the CTO position so my position was kind
of you know with a question mark should
I do like more more business development
should I go over to the tech side I kind
of figured that I have the skills for
both right yeah yeah and I was kind of
drawn into the product position without
even realizing that so I started working
on our you know creating the
requirements for our GUI and web UI and
prioritizing features and and talking to
customers simply because you know it was
kind of a gap that someone needed to
feel and it just became very natural for
me to fit into that role is it very
common for people to do the transition
you did from know being from from being
an expert in networking from the Army
and then going to doing front-end
development to then becoming a product a
product person because that I mean it's
it's a pretty it seems like a pretty
unusual unusual certain thing you're
missing two steps in the middle so from
doing like networking to to software
engineering that's like classic move
from self-renewing just you know
specializing front and back-end that I
mean obviously that's also
kind of natural and then I think not
yeah front front front end are
developing to product that's also kind
of natural also I would say from a being
QA that's also very very natural to go
to product because you're familiar with
kind of the flows of work right user so
yeah you know so just like jumping from
point A to point like D well maybe not
be natural but you know you have two
more points in the middle so that's
that's better so so throughout your
experience now at odo and from
previously what are some of the key key
you know earned secrets that that you're
taking with you as you're building new
products for the company or do you feel
like you have these sort of mantras that
you're starting to accumulate yourself
that you're taking with you yeah
definitely but unfortunately these would
be things that people repeatedly say so
I probably have nothing new to say here
except for the fact that you should
actually listen to what people say
because there is a reason for that think
that probably one of the best thing that
we did as founders as a group of three
founders that before receiving any
father before actually starting to build
the team is we went to a lot of like
lectures and just you know gatherings
around intrapreneurship and it's funny
because we had some you have some you
know Moto's that keep on repeating and
you just want to shoot yourself I mean
how many how about how much can people
repeat themselves saying the same things
but then you realize they may actually
have something behind it so I I think
that the tip about not building anything
until you get market validation it's
true for the scale of startup it's also
true for the scale of feature inside a
product that's something that actually
saved us if it wasn't for that we will
be buildings in an entirely different
product setting up a good demo I think
that's also really really important so
our flow as a company was building a
really good demo doing
POCs and then working very well at
production so it was like three steps
kind of tips were repeatedly we also we
have some tips that we didn't follow and
then really regret it in a retrospect
we're like people said we should do that
why didn't we listen to them but you
know on one hand it makes perfect sense
there are these overarching things like
finding product market fit before you go
on a growth spurt and stuff like that
but then you see companies that went
against all the odds the founders
received a million knows and they pushed
forward and sometimes those are the
companies that really revolutionized the
world you know I'm thinking about Airbnb
and I talked to quite a few investors
who passed on the opportunity to invest
in the seed stage of Airbnb because they
said who wait which person would want to
go and sleep in somebody else's
apartment and which homes would want to
so so how do you deal with that because
he knows sometimes you I'm sure you
would have these these hypotheses and
because they're not in the norm of
society then people would have matically
disregard them but you have a strong
sense and yes it could work yeah and
that's probably you know starts and ends
in gut feeling at the end of the day I
do believe that what you mean those
Cinderella stories are amazing but
they're kind of a segment so we have
from the people who succeeded you have a
very small part who I believe succeeded
kind of against all odds and from the
people who tried something against the
odds there is a very small part of
people who actually succeeded so the
intersection is quite small of people of
companies who succeeded against all odds
I think that you have I would not say
playbook but you do have those you know
thinks that you should you should go by
and obviously you know follow your heart
if you believe it's true go for it but
don't go blindly always listen always
think again see if what you're doing
makes sense because it's very easy to
fall in love with what you do and kind
of just not listen to what anything else
has to say I love it now and I have to
say that actually the way the reason
that I reached out initially is one
best friends Daniel he was a part of the
order team for quite some time and he he
said that this is one of the most
impressive teams he's ever worked with
and he he just had the time of his life
and you know just from this conversation
I can I can sort of start to sense the
culture that you're building there and
where it's headed No thank you very much
before I before I let you go back to
revolutionising the cyber security space
I want you to tell me three words that
you think best describe you I'm sorry
for putting you on the spot
you should have told me that before I
know I know well then would it have been
as authentic as it is now okay so I
would probably say ambitious kind and
[Music]
happy I love it I have to say that you
know throughout the throughout these
discussions that I'm having you can
start to see sort of a difference in how
people represent themselves when they're
in the product position will oriented
much more relationship in that
information and kind of that's actually
really interesting to see people in
different roles and how they describe
themselves that's that's exactly what
I'm going for
I'm very excited to see that new idea
first start up there you go or at least
a nice medium article with some date on
a hundred percent Noah thank you so so
much for the time